la forêt les parcs et squares les
jardins familiaux municipaux constituent
près d'un tiers de l'espace bisontin
chaque habitant de deux ensembles
dispose ainsi de près de 200 mètres
carrés des espaces verts un chiffre à
faire pâlir n'importe quel citadins
français les besoins sans essai fort et
c'est aussi une histoire racontée au
palais granvelle une histoire notamment
sous l'ancien régime de lutte incessante
entre la couronne la ville de besançon
pour s'approprier l'espace forestier la
forêt à cette époque était un enjeu
économique de taille elle permettait
entre autres l'approvisionnement des
bisontins en bois de chauffe au centre
de cette exposition la forêt de chailluz
cette exposition traite beaucoup sur un
sur schalke sont à des documents qui
nous viennent de la bibliothèque
municipale et qui date du 14ème siècle
lens on a la chance de posséder un
patrimoine foncier assez exceptionnel
dont la forêt de chailluz qui couvre ses
100 hectares et il y à un plusieurs
années la municipalité a décidé d'ouvrir
une partie de cette forêt aux mille ont
peint par divers aménagements tels que
piste cyclable parc forestier parc
animalier également des places déplace à
feu coin pique nique parcours sportif
une dernière réalisation
si aujourd'hui donc le patrimoine
forestier est un élément indispensable à
la population pour la qualité de la vie
et ses loisirs il n'en reste pas moins
que la forêt est fragile il faut la
préserver soigner les arbres atteints
d'une maladie respecte l équilibre
écologique lutter contre les agressions
humaines naturelles autant aspects
abordés dans cette exposition que vous
pourrez visiter jusqu'au 8 septembre